hey guys I'm Jessa McDonald's you are
tuned into games but you and it's the
tenth of much already when did that
happen first our theme cool technology
news that may one day affect a video
games Panasonic and Sony have announced
a new next-gen blu-ray disc the fancy
little thing is called an archival disc
and will be able to hold one terabyte of
data a Panasonic representative has said
that it's intended to be used for
professional purposes and not so much
for your average Joe consumer that if
you can get your hands on one then go
nuts currently blu-ray discs only store
up to 50 gigabytes of data archival disk
systems will launch in the summer of
2015 with the first versions featuring
300 gigabytes of storage space and now
for that dreaded resolution news that a
lot of you don't care about titanfall
will not be launching with a better
resolution than it featured in the beta
the 792 p res will be what gamers can
expect from the final version despite
the fact that we were told we might see
something a little more impressive by
launch respawn confirmed the news that
have added that they're still working on
it and expect to increase the resolution
after they ship the death have said they
need time to optimize and figure out how
to mess with embedded SRAM and other
hardware techy things to get the best
possible result as for pesky frame rates
lead engineer Richard Baker said the
mass scale fights wouldn't facilitate
60fps but they're working to condense
the system and make this a possibility
did you guys expect respawn to pull out
a better resolution for the final
version of titanfall or not or are you
just gonna play on PC let me know last
up we all pretty much saw xboxes games
with gold and PlayStation Plus as
essentially the same thing but Phil
Spencer has come out to say they are
actually fundamentally different
according to the Xbox exactly this is
because xboxes service lets you keep the
games whether or not you continue to pay
for a subscription while plus doesn't
work like that although Spencer added
this does impact upon what games they
can include with the program according
to polygon Spencer said that he is
playing a more active role in picking
franchises that appear in games with
gold this month selection includes sid
meier's civilization rebel
ocean and dungeon defenders let me know
whether you prefer the title selection
on games with gold or if you prefer
what's on PlayStation Plus you can drop
me your thoughts in the comments down
below or on my Twitter where I'm at just
McDonald that is it for me today but
i'll be back with more news tomorrow so
i'll hope to see you then